if lockdown and homeschooling taught us
anything as parents is that that job is
super hard you can say that and again
they're underpaid yes
absolutely a campaign ambassador and
australia's most famous math teacher
eddie wu joins us now from his sydney
classroom hey eddie
dave belinda thanks for having me oh
great to see you back in that classroom
it must be so nice to have the students
back as well
uh it's been awesome look obviously it's
a challenge teaching with your mask on
and there's a lot of complexity but
we're still navigating with students all
coming back and vaccinations but there's
nothing like the energy you get from
your students face to face and also the
insight from when i'm teaching something
i need to be able to look carefully at
what they understand and what they don't
like teaching is a dance and you want to
have that partnership between what
they're comprehending and what you need
to help them with so i'm very glad to be
back yeah and you know what you've kind
of were pioneering this whole zoom
teaching weren't you because you were
doing your maths videos on youtube for
years now i mean that channel did that
channel help you and your students keep
track during lockdown
oh absolutely i mean for some very
obvious reasons i mean for starters
having all the gear that's kind of
become second nature now to so many
teachers as they've been creating their
own video lessons for their students
that's been very helpful but the thing
that stood out to me most is actually
supporting other teachers so we've seen
so many people from all around the world
who've all been wrestling with learning
from home be able to adapt these
resources and that's been a real
pleasure to see the the uptake there
yeah great everyone's supporting each
other uh talk to us about the hashtag
brightfuture campaign what's it all
about
yeah so again like you guys mentioned
this is about celebrating world teachers
day and obviously i am biased but i
think many people have had a visceral
experience over the last 18 months of
the difference that educators make in
our children's lives and i count myself
in that as well my three children are i
think that the experience of their
teachers has been incredible in trying
to support them through very difficult
circumstances so um you can go to the
world teacher's day website it's
worldteachersday.edu.edu
you can play some games take a selfie
there's also a kit to help you celebrate
if you want to show appreciation to your
teachers um all the things that we hope
will celebrate the bright future the
teachers help students to have well you
know what and it's because of all i
teach out there that our kids have
actually gotten through this so we thank
you eddie for being here and to everyone
who tried their absolute donors to keep
their kids on track thanks eddie we'll
speak to you soon thanks eddie